let's see how to pre-process a data set
for summarization
this is a task of while summarizing a
long document
this video will focus on how to
preprocess your data set once you've
managed to put it in the following
format
one column for the long documents and
one for the summaries
here is how we can achieve this with the
datasets library on the xm dataset
as long as you manage to have your data
look like this you should be able to
follow the same steps
for once all labels are not integers
corresponding to some classes but plain
text
all of us need to tokenize them like our
inputs
whereas a small trap variable as we need
to tokenize our targets inside the ask
target tokenizer context manager
this is because the special token swim
ad might be slightly different for the
inputs on the target
so the tokenizer has to know which one
it is processing
processing the world data set is then
super easy with the map function
since the summaries are usually much
shorter than the documents you should
definitely pick different maximum
lengths for the inputs and targets
you can choose to pad at this stage to
that maximum length by setting padding
equal max length
here we'll show you how to buy
dynamically as it requires one more step
your inputs and targets are all
sentences of various lengths
we'll pass the inputs and targets
separately as the maximum length of the
inputs and targets are completely
different
then we pad the inputs to the maximum
length among the inputs and same for the
target
we pad the inputs with the pad token and
the targets with the -100 index to make
sure they are not taken into account in
the loss computation
the transformers library provides us
with a data creditor to do this all
automatically
you can then pass it to the trainer with
your data sets or use it in the tf
dataset method before using
model.loadfit on your keras model